- All right, hi.
Welcome to DAT315.
Hopefully some of you are
practitioners in data, maybe.
Right, I'm a practitioner in data.
Maybe you're a practitioner in agentic AI.
Anybody?
Well, by the end of this,
hopefully you'll probably
be practitioners in data
and agentic AI together.
So that's what we aim to do.
My name's Tim, I'm a senior
principal engineer in Aurora.
I'll be joined shortly by my friend Siva,
who's the director
of Worldwide Specialist
Solutions Architects,
and we're gonna talk about
practitioner's guide to data
for agentic AI.
So if anybody thinks they've
completely got their arms
around all of this, congratulations,
you're doing better than most
of the rest of the world.
This is changing really fast.
So the first thing I wanna do is just
look at this evolving
landscape a little bit.
So we started off in 2023.
Not very long ago we had these chat bots,
we were talking about vector search,
we were talking about LLMs just beginning.
We had these single shot
interactions with the agents,
that's what we could do.
Then in 2024, we got these
more advanced chat bots.
We got context, the ability
for an agent to remember
a little bit about what it was doing,
to do hybrid search, to
bring in other data types.
In here we had RAG, retrieval
augmented generation.
That was all the rage last year.
That was so 2024.
Then, near the end of 2024,
came MCP, Model Context Protocol,
which gave these agents some
tools to talk to each other
in data sources.
It standardized things.
And then now 2025, nearly the end,
we got to autonomous AI agents.
They can reason and plan
and they can execute tasks.
This all happened in, count
'em, just a few years.
And we are still, I don't
think anywhere near the end.
But now we can have a much
more natural conversation
with our agents,
and they can do things much
more autonomously for us.
So today we're gonna follow an example.
We're gonna buy some car insurance,
which is, I think, what everybody
loves to do all the time.
Buy some car insurance,
and we're gonna pretend that we are Terry,
who wants to buy some car insurance.
Back in 2023, your AI experience
would've been interesting,
but it would've been
probably just a thin wrapper
around some pre-processing
and then hand off to a human
to actually do the work.
Now in 2025 with our auto insurer example,
the agent's able to have a
much more fluid conversation,
and it's able to actually
do probably the entire task
for Terry rather than, excuse me,
rather than handing off to a human.
Whether we like it or not.
That's what's gonna happen.
That's what we're gonna dig through today.
So we'll cover some fundamentals.
We've got these three
pillars of agentic AI.
So first off, we have reasoning.
This is where we use our
large language models
and then we have action.
We are able to take
action from these models.
We're gonna call some tools,
we're gonna do some things
as instructed by the LLMs.
And then we have this memory.
We have to remember things.
Otherwise it's like talking to a goldfish.
You can't remember anything.
It's very frustrating, not very useful.
The agentic AI thing, the
special sauce there is,
we put this in a loop.
We're able to iterate this,
and if you've done any
computer science stuff,
writing a program without loops,
pretty difficult, pretty boring.
Once we've got this loop, this ReAct loop,
reason and act loop, now
we're in agentic AI space.
That's where we are today.
Okay, so any company car insurance,
Terry needs to buy some car insurance.
We'll come through this
loop probably a ton of times
before we make some answer,
like, "Your insurance quote is X dollars,
thanks for your business."
Okay, so we'll dig in just
in one iteration of that loop
to start with, reasoning and planning.
So the user puts in their request.
Inside here we have the system prompt.
We are managing context.
The system prompt comes in,
we have some existing state, maybe,
we have the user request come in, saying,
"Oh I need insurance for
my Buick or whatever."
Next part, we go through the LLM.
The LLM does magic stuff.
I'm not a scientist who can tell you
about how LLMs actually do their work.
And then we pass the
output from this thing.
We make an action plan,
agent makes an action plan.
We need to work out
what the next step in the action plan is.
We might be stopping,
we might be sending a
response back to the user.
We talk about this acting
and managing context thing,
'cause that's where we can
first start to talk about data.
After we've called a tool,
or maybe we call the tool to get the data
and send a response back to the user.
So that tool does whatever
the tool's gonna do,
and then it maybe
accessed some data store.
This is what we're gonna talk about today.
And then we're gonna feed these results
into this context manager.
And that's gonna maybe do some caching,
it's gonna do some updating
the conversation history,
so we can remember.
And it's also gonna
evaluate what it was doing
for reinforcement learning,
so that we can make a better
experience of this iteration
for the next time we come through,
maybe for the next customer.
That's important as well.
So knowing all of that,
we'll actually step through
our car insurance example
just a little bit,
and I need you to pay
attention to the colors here.
So the first interaction says,
from the customer, Terry,
"I need some car insurance."
We get the system prompt,
that's the purple thing here.
We go to the agent, we give that,
we give whatever other context we have,
maybe from previous conversation
history or something.
We format this up, we give it to the LLM,
it does whatever its does,
we get the output out again.
We determine the next step,
and maybe the next step is to call a tool.
Now this is the first interaction.
So we dunno anything
about this customer yet.
So we need to just call a tool
called get_driver_details.
We need to work out what this
driver's history is about.
So this gives us a purple kind of result.
So now we're gonna go
around this loop again.
You can see in this state
we've remembered the purple result.
We remember the driver's information,
and now we're gonna go around
and we're gonna invoke a different tool
to find out about the
vehicle's information.
Again, the pink information
comes in, we remember that,
now we're gonna sort
of calculate some risk
about that vehicle and that person.
Again, we're gonna get a quote.
So see how this the
context is stacking up.
Finally, we have enough
information to generate a response
for the user, give it to the user,
and wait for their input returning again.
You can see how the context,
all those colors are stacking up together.
So this is great.
What happens, though, when
we need to keep going,
that context is not infinitely large.
I'm a really good artist, you
can see from my great colors.
So we need to do something
called compaction
on our context here.
What we've done is we've
merged those colors.
So there's a few different
algorithms we can be using here.
You don't have to worry
about this too much.
The framework provides it for you,
but we can be doing summarization,
we can be asking the LLM
to summarize it for you,
we can be doing simple
like least recently used
kind of thing in there.
Different algorithms
to throw away the bits
that we maybe don't want,
remember the bits that we do.
The important thing is that
we've gone around this loop
seven times in this case,
and we've remembered
most of what we've done.
That's the react loop.
So the memory thing, this
is the interesting part.
We've got this continuum,
short-term memory on the left,
long-term memory on the right.
We're gonna dig into this
some more with agentic memory.
In the short term memory,
we have this agent state.
This is kind of like the agent's RAM,
if you like to think about it that way.
It's working memory.
This is where the framework's
probably dealing with it
for you, you probably don't actually
have to code this thing up yourself.
You want it to be fast.
It might be like
ElastiCache for Valkey here.
Strands Agents as a framework,
LangGraph as a framework,
they typically provide these
things for you, all right?
And they're simple to
use, small, short term.
And in the middle we have this
medium term semantic memory,
episodic memory.
So this is typically, we are
retrieving it using tools.
We're going through a tool
to get to the source of the memory
or to put stuff into the memory there.
This is where we'll talk
about enterprise databases,
vector stores, other things like that.
So you probably are more
aware of what's going on here.
Then on the far right we have prompts.
So this is more, you're
probably treating them
like infrastructure as
code kind of things.
This is where your builders are
putting in the system prompt
to say you are an insurance agent,
here are your guardrails
and things like that.
You're probably manage them like code
in a code artifact repository,
or a key value store,
or something like that.
You're not accessing them very often.
You're not modifying them very often.
That's the way to think about
these three kinds of memory.
Okay, so now we're just gonna
see a little bit of code.
I'm an engineer, this
makes it look easier to me.
We have two different examples here.
I've chosen Strands Agents
and LangChain and LangGraph.
Now if you don't follow
code, that's completely fine,
'cause there's not really very much here.
All we really need to focus
on is just couple of lines
at the top there which says I'm gonna use
an AgentCore session memory
manager in this case.
You could use another one.
I'm gonna use a conversation manager,
summarizing conversation
manager in this case.
That's one that uses that
summarization algorithm
to smush the colors together
like I showed before.
And then I'm just gonna pass
it down to the framework.
That's it.
In the LangChain version,
it's pretty similar.
They just use a different name for things
and bundle it all together
into a thing called a check pointer.
Same idea.
So you're not really
writing all this code,
the agent's probably
writing it for you anyway.
But very simple.
Okay, so we'll dig in a little bit more.
We'll just talk about how we
connect the agents to the data.
So we get our inbound user query,
we go through an MCP server, probably.
We'll dig into what that
means in a little bit,
and we'll talk to some database
to maybe get customer profiles.
And then we'll go around again,
maybe we'll talk to a different database
to get vehicle data and telemetry,
and we'll go around again.
You can see we are talking to
different kinds of databases.
Maybe they're relational ones,
maybe they're key value ones,
maybe they're vector ones.
Maybe some of them belong
to our company already.
Maybe some of them are third party ones,
like the Department of Motor
Vehicles in my example.
You're calling these things
all through tools, MCP service.
All right, so the same
basic pattern is applied
across everything here.
That's the joy of MCP.
We don't have to write
all this special code
to deal with this.
So how did we get there?
Those tools, we need to find them first.
So the same example, we just
look at the other part there.
I'm creating an agent,
instantiating an agent,
I'm creating a bedrock
model to go with it,
and I'm giving it a list of tools.
There are four tools there,
search documents and so on,
and a system prompt, you
are an insurance agent.
Now I'm not in love with
how I had to specify
or hard code the tool names there,
so I'm gonna come back
to that one in a minute.
But you can still see
this as pretty simple.
I'm going to change gears a little bit
and talk about the power of
caching here for a minute.
So you know all the fundamentals here.
You would've probably
noticed that every time
we go around this loop,
we seem like we're doing
a bunch of maybe duplicate work.
We're fetching some data
again, over and over again.
Maybe some of that will
make things slower.
cost us some more money.
We don't like that.
Caching is a pretty natural approach here.
So here's our similar picture,
and we'll talk about places
where we can put caching into this.
Why would we do it?
We can reduce latency,
that's pretty standard.
These LLMs, large language models,
they're not called SLMs,
small language models.
They have a bit of a cost to them.
So if we can avoid calling them,
or we can avoid using
up their token space,
we can save ourselves money and time.
So caching is a really
good way to do that.
Even if the backend system is not an LLM,
if it's some other kind of database,
it still has a finite capacity
to deliver some performance.
So reducing load on that's
probably good as well.
And again, with this
reinforcement learning thing,
caching is a really
important way to get signals
to see if something is popular.
So if I'm getting lots
of hits in the cache,
then it's probably a popular thing,
and I should cache it more,
and I should update my plan
to do more of this thing.
So where can we insert some caches?
Over on the right hand side,
this is the closest to the data source.
So the lowest in the stack, if you like.
This is probably the most familiar
to what you do already today.
You've got a database, you
put a cache in front of it,
right, an ElastiCache
or something like that.
This makes your tool responses faster,
but it doesn't do anything to
avoid going around this loop.
Just lets you go around
this loop a bit quicker.
So it probably doesn't save you any money
or context on your LLMs.
Next step up, we can put a cache
in the memory context manager
just after it's called the tool.
All right, this is on the tool results.
So this might reduce your LLM usage.
This is the first one that does this.
You can reuse an existing
action plan maybe
and the sequence of tools
that are gonna be called,
so you don't have to
ask the LLM to do this
every single time.
This is pretty optimistic
if it helps here,
but it's useful to think about.
Next we can cache
on the other side of the
memory context manager,
on the output side if you like.
So this is within the scope
of a user's session, probably.
So if your session contains a
lot of cacheable information,
messages that don't change very
often, like in our example,
we're going around and telling
them the vehicle information
over and over again, that kind of thing.
That's the kind of thing
we'll be using here.
This won't affect your
LLM usage appreciably,
but it will make things go a lot quicker.
And finally you can
implement a semantic cache,
which is as close to
the user as you can get
before this whole loop iterates at all.
So if this works for you, this
is really, really powerful,
because you can avoid calling everything.
Now this works for things
where you don't have personal information
inside your agent responses.
Maybe your agent was being
asked a question like,
just tell me the legal requirements
for insurance in Nevada.
There's nothing specific to me about that.
So I could cache that response.
That's the kind of thing
we would use there.
So this saves latency, saves cost,
makes your customers happier,
'cause their interactions are more smooth.
Right, so now you're all kind of experts,
or maybe you're all just bedazzled.
So one thing that, I'm a
crusty old Unix gray beard.
And so I would like to share
with you a bit of an analogy
to see if this helps understand
what's going on here a little bit.
So I'm gonna draw an
analogy between agentic AI
and relational databases.
If you know relational databases,
great, maybe this works.
If you don't, don't worry.
It's not gonna be on the
take home assignment.
So first we'll talk about the interface.
What's the interface into
a relational database?
Well, it's SQL and it's JDBC.
It's all this very standardized stuff.
And Agentic AI is getting
that as well with MCP.
So they're kind of similar.
Then there's this idea of memory
we've been talking about along today.
You've got short term
memory and long term memory
for agentic AI.
And inside a relational database,
of course you've got
memory, you've got B-trees,
you've got heaps, you've got indexes,
you've got all that kind of thing.
Then there's the execution angle to this.
So we just talked about this react loop
where we plan and then we
execute the steps of the plan.
Well, in a SQL engine, you
have a SQL query planner
that's planning how to use
indexes, and heap sorts,
and all those other kinds of things.
Quite similar.
And we got caching we just talked about.
That's very one for one.
Databases work heavily on caching.
And finally we've got this
thing we call canned execution.
So MCP, you can put whatever tool you like
behind an MCP server to execute
whatever operation you want,
and inside a SQL engine
you have stored procedures,
you have PLPG SQL, got lots
of other pre-canned execution.
If that makes you draw a
complete blank, I'm sorry.
If this helps, maybe it's good for you.
All right, so MCP, model context protocol.
We dig into this a little bit more.
So this standardizes the
interaction between your agents
and the tools that they're
calling in two ways.
It lets them find the tools
that they're gonna call,
work out what they're for,
and it lets them call them.
Two very important separate steps.
So here's our car insurance agent.
Inside that agent, there's an MCP client,
standard Python, it's
talking to an MCP server.
MCP server advertises, in
this case, three tools,
get owner vehicles and so on.
The tools have parameters,
they have some documentation
that goes with them to tell the humans
and to tell the tool what they do.
That tool probably
calls off to a database,
so it's just doing normal stuff.
It's like running a
regular database driver,
talking to a regular relational,
maybe, database, okay?
It's nothing magic once you
get underneath MCP server.
So we'll zoom in, next level down.
That agent embeds that MCP client.
What is the MCP server actually doing?
So inside the agent,
we have a tool catalog.
It's now got two tools inside it.
How did they get there?
Well, the MCP server
advertises these two tools.
There's an MCP operation
called tools/list.
MCP works on JSSON-RPC.
So the first thing that
the MCP client does is say,
list me the tools, and
you'll get vehicle by VIN,
get vehicle owners, get owner vehicles.
We know how to call them or
add them into our catalog.
And the agent understands
then how it's useful
to call that tool.
So you don't have to tell
the agent call the tool,
which is named X with parameters Y.
It's already worked all this out.
That's the job of the tool catalog,
which got discovered by using MCP.
So that hard coding that I
didn't like in the example
gets replaced by this.
We don't hard code tools anymore.
You can if you like,
but you don't have to.
Now we can have many MCP servers
plugged into one of our
agents, one of our MCP clients.
So we can continue to build our catalog
by querying multiple MCP
servers along the way.
And this is how we build, for example,
our internal data stores, and
then we talk to the DMV ones,
and the other ones that we're
trying to build up over time.
Okay, so we're building this catalog,
this is all internal to how MCP works.
So let's implement an
MCP client and server,
those purple boxes that we had before.
Little bit more Python.
On the left, standard MCP
SDK, nothing to do with me.
All we're doing is we're
creating a client session.
On the right hand side, MCP server.
This is the thing that's maybe off
talking to your database and so on.
Important part on the client side.
We initialize the session
and we call that list tools function.
That's it.
On the right hand side,
there's actually no
python code there at all
that's interesting, there's
just a couple of decorators,
the little pink things,
and all they say is,
this function is the
function I want you to call
when you want to list
the tools, for example,
or call the tools.
So the takeaway for you here, I hope,
is that it's very, very
low barrier to entry here.
Making an MCP server, not too difficult.
Just put a couple of
annotations on the code
that you probably already have.
All right, so as we go on,
we've gotta talk about how
to choose the right tools
for the right job.
So I've kind of made this taxonomy here.
We've got the X axis is read only,
data retrieval versus data mutation,
and the Y axis is whether
it's a general purpose tool,
where it can do pretty much anything,
or a specialized tool like
we've been talking about so far.
So on the top left there,
we have general purpose
retrieval tools, read only tools.
So this is maybe your business analyst
inside an insurance company,
which needs the full power of a SQL query,
a read only SQL query,
and it wants to call this
through Agentic AI workflow.
So this might be the MCP server,
tools that we ship inside AWS
for a bunch of our databases
like Aurora DSQL.
And on the right hand side of that,
you've got the data
mutation version of that.
This is very powerful.
This is basically general
purpose SQL execution
or something like that.
They can create, they can delete,
and they can read general
purpose data in your data stores.
You're probably not giving
that to your customers.
You're probably giving that
to your internal developers.
Maybe you're accessing that through KIRO
or something like that, Claude code.
Now down the bottom, the
specialized read only calls,
that's like what we've been
making in our examples so far.
The get vehicle by VIN
and that kind of thing.
We are getting, so it's read
only, but it's specialized.
I can't go and learn about tractors,
I can only learn about cars or something.
And then the data
mutating versions of that,
the specialized one.
So in our example, this is
maybe when we get to the end
and we wanna save the
progress on the quote
or we want to calculate some
premium or something like that.
So this is your highest business value
is packed into probably
that bottom row there,
the specialized ones,
they're the tools that you are building
for your customers to call.
They're for frequently executed tasks.
So it's worthwhile you
investing the effort in there.
And they'll give the
higher performance as well.
So now that we have this
taxonomy, we can see how that maps
to the personas of the users
that you are maybe trying
to have inside your business
or as your customers.
So the top left, you have the data analyst
or the engineer, they're
doing those read-only queries
against the general purpose data.
If I took the words MCP
out of your mind right now,
this picture probably looks
pretty familiar anyway.
This is what business
intelligence tools and so on do,
and MCP, just giving you a
different lens to think about it.
Top right, that's your developers
and your DevOps people.
And down the bottom, it's
your end users and consumers,
depending if they're
doing reads and writes.
So hopefully that sets the framework here
so that we can think about this some more.
I'm gonna hand over to Siva now
and he's gonna tell us about
the data behind the tools.
- Thank you, Tim.
So good afternoon everyone.
So where does the data
behind the tool comes from?
And you're probably wondering,
I already have a lot of
challenges on my data side,
I have data quality issues,
maybe I need to figure out
how to get data lineage.
And then how do I have an
existing system that's working?
Then maybe you have some APIs.
How do I convert that into an MCP tool,
hand this off to the the agent,
and what happens to
security along end to end?
This is what customers are asking us.
The next section I'm gonna go through
how to address these challenges.
Also, as an architect,
I always think about,
is there a reference architecture
that I can give customers?
So I kept the best for the last.
So I think we're gonna
end the presentation
with the reference architecture
and a call to action, obviously.
So let's dive in.
So where does, on a technical level,
where does the data come from?
The data comes from your
operational databases.
This could be MySQL, or Postgres, Oracle,
or SQL server that you're running,
or it could be NoSQL
databases such as DynamoDB,
DocumentDB, MongoDB and other things.
It could also come from
your data warehouses,
data warehouses such as Redshift,
or Snowflake, or others.
Or you probably have data
in an Open Table format,
like Iceberg, and you
probably have this data
in a parquet format on top of S3.
SageMaker LakeHouse.
Or other LakeHouses,
or maybe you have a streaming data
coming into your organization
that is in your streaming data source,
such as Kinesis or Kafka.
Now, let's look at this
challenge from a business level.
Like this is anycompany.com insurance.
This is an example company
that Tim alluded to
that Terry is gonna buy an
insurance from this company.
When you look at this, in Any Company,
there's multiple departments.
For example, the claims history
comes from the claims department.
They are data producers of this data set.
And then maybe the legal
department has information
about rules and regulations,
and then potentially this
company sources data from the DMV
in terms of accident
records and other things.
If they have pay-as-you-go insurance,
maybe that data has to be sourced
from some telemetric data sets.
So essentially you have data producers
and data consumers in the setup.
And then, well, anytime you
have multiple departments,
producers, and consumers
you're dealing with data silos
and data quality issues come in.
If, for example, the sales
and marketing department
have information about the customer,
all the fields have to kind of be merged
and then the customer
360 should reflect that.
And then the data lineage issues.
How do we track data lineage?
There's this personally
identifiable information,
such as social security number.
If there is a collision, there's a claim,
then there's some medical
information involved.
You cannot pass this on to every user.
And then access control,
who has access to this?
What are their entitlements?
So all of these challenges get magnified
in the world of agents, because
agents are applications,
they're going much faster than the humans.
They know how to navigate various paths.
And then you wanna make sure
you are sending them on
along the right paths,
there's proper governance along the way
and proper security checks along the way,
and filters along the way,
so they don't hand off
the incorrect data set
to the end user or an internal user.
So how do we address that?
As an architect, probably you're familiar
with the data marketplace architecture.
People call this data
mesh and other things.
I'm gonna use the term data
marketplace architecture.
What this architecture says is,
let's imagine our
company as data producers
and data consumers.
For example, the claims department
is a data producer of claims.
And then the underwriting department,
which consumes this data set
and evaluates the customer risk,
is actually a data consumer.
Then typically data
producers are responsible
for data quality.
Because they produce the data,
it's probably much easy for them
to actually put some data quality rules,
ensure that this data that they produce
actually conforms to the standards
that they expect the data to be at.
And then data consumers, like
this underwriting department
is the data consumer.
Typically they discover the data set
and then they subscribe to the data set.
So we can use these
primitives to help us address
some of these issues as well.
So let's see, there's probably three steps
that you want to do.
First build data products marketplace.
Now, when I say this to customers,
they often ask us like,
"Well, that's gonna
take a couple of years,
maybe more to do that."
So here's where I think we need to be
a little more pragmatic.
You can boil the ocean and
build all these data products
for your company.
Probably you should be
keeping keep on doing that.
But as you identify some important
use cases for agentic AI,
you should probably
prioritize those use cases
and build data products relevant to them,
identify the data producers and consumers,
and get started there
to be fairly pragmatic.
And then now, how do we feed
this data products to agents?
Let's build some data APIs on top of them.
If you have a claims history,
given the customer information,
it could actually get all
the claims information
pertaining to that customer.
Why should we do that?
The fact that you created a data product,
maybe that's a table in your Lakehouse,
the agent is able to
actually select everything
from the table,
but actually you wanna
be a little more careful.
You want to create a specialized path.
So if you're an external customer
coming through your agent
and asking for that,
you want to actually restrict that use
to just the data set that belongs to them.
Like building an API on top
of that makes a lot of sense.
And the other thing is like,
nobody can do this for you.
You own your data, you
know what this data set is,
you know what your business
procedures or practices are,
and this belongs to us, as
data producers and consumers,
to actually build these APIs.
And then again, one of
the other challenges
with agents and our
industry right now is that,
everything is changing by
the day or by the week.
How do I, as an architect,
I always think about,
how do I build things in a
completely changing world?
So I build primitives, but
those can be extremely helpful,
now today, tomorrow, and day after.
And then obviously I can
leverage the agentic IDs
to build these APIs that are
making my life a lot easier.
But you do have to verify them,
you have to build them yourself.
After we do that, then the
next thing is to hand this off.
How do we hand this off to the agent?
We can expose this API as MCP tools.
Tim went through an example.
Here's where things like AgentCore gateway
are gonna come in fairly handy.
You know, as long as you have an API,
you can actually define that
API using open API standard,
you can register that with the AgentCore.
It'll actually expose that API
as an MCP server undertool on your behalf.
So you don't necessarily have to do that.
Or, if you want to actually create an API,
you could simply write a
lambda function in Python
or your favorite language,
and then expose that to AgentCore gateway,
and therefore magically
these tools are available
for your agents.
Now, when you do that, what happens?
Your agent has the brain to
pick the right tool for the job.
When the user says, I want
a specific functionality,
it is able to reason out that request,
it looks in the tool
repository that it has
and identifies the right tool for the job.
Or you can guide this by
prompt templates as well.
So we maybe addressed some
of the data silos issues.
Let's say, let's take these principles
and apply this to how do you
move a traditional application
to an agentic AI application?
Before we get there, I wanna address,
we should understand who the audience is,
who the user is of this agentic experience
that we're creating.
Again, I'm gonna go back into
the AnyCompany insurance.
It's easier to explain there.
So Tim talked about Terry
wanting to buy car insurance,
or maybe filing a claim.
That's one class of users.
People outside our company
that want to get something done
talking to us.
That's the external customer.
Now, when you look within the company,
this may be data producers
and data consumers.
In this case I'm gonna use Nikki,
as Nikki is a claims investigator.
Nikki wants to actually
look at all the claims
that happened in a specific state.
Nikki is responsible
for the state of Nevada.
And then when she investigates the claims,
she wants to get all the
claims beyond a certain value
and take a look at this, just
to see if there's any fraud.
That's an internal user.
And then again, you could
have data engineers,
like in this case, Jane is a data engineer
and wants to build a new data product.
You know, I talked about this telematics.
Maybe she wants to subscribe
a telematics data set
from a telematics provider
and then host the
dataset as a data product
that the underwriting department
and others can consume.
So in general, you can generalize this to,
there are potentially three access paths
for our agentic applications.
Now, with that as the backdrop, Terry,
maybe this AnyCompany doesn't
have an agentic experience.
Today, what Terry does
is maybe goes through
an insurance website, fills
out the appropriate form,
and says, "I wanna buy insurance,
or I want to file a claim."
Now, how do we transform that
into an agentic experience?
You potentially already have the API,
when you fill out the
form and Terry submits it,
chances are your web server
is already calling an API
and that's implemented in
your application server.
And by simply converting
that into an MCP tool,
all of a sudden you can hook that tool
up to your agentic application
and great, now voila,
you have the agentic
experience that you can present
and start building on this one.
So in general, what we see play out today,
it's not a complete revolution.
The moving an application
from non-agentic experience
to an agentic experience is an
evolution for most customers.
And this thinking of the
existing functionality as an API,
exposing that as an MCP tool,
and handing it off with an
agent is a powerful mechanism
to actually plug that in.
Now, we talked about RAG.
Two years ago, RAG was the answer
no matter what the question was.
RAG hasn't gone anywhere else.
Like the beauty of RAG is that,
if I say I live in the state of Nevada
and I want insurance, it's able to say,
"Maybe there's some rules and regulations
associated with that."
If you have a vector database
with all these documents
that explains the rules
of buying insurance
in the state of Nevada,
maybe that's already chunked
and then stored in a vector data store.
And what this does is, given a string,
I wanna buy car insurance,
it retrieves the related information
and then hands it off to the agentic,
the reasoning loop.
And then now you can simply
expose that as an API, too.
Input is a string and
output is a set of documents
that comes in.
So you could potentially expose them
as semantic APIs as well.
Now let's look at the
internal user experience.
How does this play out?
So in the case of internal user,
again, I'm gonna take Nikki,
who's a data consumer.
And then in this case,
Jane is a data producer.
Typically today Nikki goes to
sort of a BI tool of some sort
and says, hey, gimme the list of claims
that are greater than a certain value,
maybe sort this, and then
let's pick the top five or 10,
and then she starts investigating that.
And that's the current experience.
Now Jane probably, to move this data set,
Jane probably wants to
figure out how to subscribe
to this telematics provider
since it's IoT data,
land this data in Kinesis,
for example, or Kafka,
and build some kind of
a streaming workflow
to build data pipelines to land this
in an Open Table format on S3.
That's the current path.
Now, AWS is very busy
building a lot of MCP servers
for all the services that we have.
When I looked at it, we
had various MCP servers
and various levels of maturity.
As Tim pointed out you can
build these things yourself
if you want to enhance them as well.
And then imagine all your query engines
and data processing engines as front-ended
by the MCP servers and tools.
As soon as you register
the tool with your agent,
now all of a sudden Nikki can,
rather than specifying
writing the SQL query,
could simply ask the agent,
"Hey, gimme a list of high value claims
in the state of Nevada."
As simple as that, the underlying tool
knows how to convert that,
we'll go through the complete
end-to-end experience
in a little bit.
Similarly, Jane could come
up with a long-term memory,
a prompt template.
In the data engineering team,
maybe there's a data engineering agent
that they have trained
with templates that say,
here's what you do when
you actually have IoT data.
Maybe you want to use,
maybe the organizational
standard is Kafka, maybe use MSK,
which is a managed service for Kafka.
Maybe they're familiar with Spark,
maybe they want to use Spark Streaming.
If all of this is templated,
again, Jane could simply say,
"Hey, by the way, can you
please create me an MSK topic,
a Kafka topic, and get the data
from this third party provider,
and then stage this in S3."
It knows what the tools
are, it's able to actually
go through the reasoning loop, understand,
get the confirmation from Jane,
and deploy this whole thing.
That magic happens by simply exposing
your existing functionality as tools
to your agentic applications.
And with that, now we
are getting into, okay,
looks pretty good, right?
Now, how does really governance
work under the covers?
It's kind of pretty important.
And then let's actually
play this thing out,
like, how does this really work?
when Nikki, as a claims
investigator, she has a role,
and user roles of a claim investigator.
Say, "Show me all the high value claims
in the state of Nevada."
What happens?
The moment Nikki connects to the agent,
the agent kind of inherits
that characteristic,
assumes the agent that
I'm an investigator.
And then what happens is that
it is smart enough to say,
by the way, Nikki is asking
something about the collision,
claims, et cetera.
I need to look up in the
business catalog what this means.
So assuming you have the tool registered,
what it does is it does, let me look,
let me find the data product.
And then it actually
calls kind of a SageMaker
business catalog and says,
hey, you have any data
products pertaining to claims?
There's metadata in this catalog
that says what those data products are,
claims and policies, et cetera.
Then as soon as the first call goes out,
it gets a list of claims and policies.
Now, since the tool, the agent here
inherits the investigator
role, it has restrictions.
It cannot look at all the data products.
It only has access to what a
claims investigator department
has access to.
Basically, it only only
lists all the data products
from their catalog that's
relevant to the user,
that's relevant to this use
case that Nikki has access to.
Again, the similar thing happens.
The next thing it does is
it takes the data product
and says it's backed
by a couple of tables,
the claims tables and the policy tables.
Then it looks up in the technical catalog
and says, lemme get the
structure of these tables.
And then once it gets that, again,
the context keeps on
building, as Tim showed you,
we're in that loop building the context
for this agentic application.
And the next thing it does is
like, well, I have the table,
now I need to retrieve data from this.
It says, let me call,
I have a list of tools.
AWS has created the data
processing MCP server
that has Athena as an engine.
So it says, hey, let
me actually use Athena,
which is like query as
a query as a service,
and then I don't have to
provision a cluster, et cetera.
I can simply present the
query, it'll execute that
and get me the results.
It fires off a session into Athena,
simply packages the select
statement it has built
from the table metadata.
Remember, Nikki doesn't say
anything about the query.
The agent builds it for her
and then passes it on to Athena.
Now Athena also, before retrieving this,
it talks to Lake Formation,
and then it applies some filters,
column level filters
and role level filters.
Let's say, if the dataset and the claims
has some personally
identifiable information,
and then it has for all the states,
it actually looks at the query and says,
well, you're asking for all
this dataset, every dataset.
Now I'm not gonna allow you to do that.
Lake Formation says, I'm
gonna put a column filter,
I'm gonna rewrite your query
and put a where clause,
because you're only
responsible for Nevada.
I'm gonna only show you
records from Nevada,
and then I'm gonna
actually mask and remove
this social security number column.
You shouldn't have access to that.
That happens automatically.
Isn't that pretty amazing?
Now, remember, the user
didn't ask anything about it.
It's simply looking at Lake Formation,
looking at the permission,
and this thing magically
happens under the covers.
And then the regular
thing happens after that,
Athena executes the query,
again, in the context of an investigator,
and then ensures that only she has access,
the other agent has
access to only the portion
of the S3 key space, and to
get this to retrieve this data,
and then it sends back to the user,
and then it the agent creates a report,
and then sends it back to Nikki.
This is how governance plays
out for an internal consumer.
Now, let's actually look at
some of the critical pieces
that the agentic data
consumer priorities are.
Like, if you are capturing an
experience to a data consumer,
you should be worried about data quality.
In the loop, if there
is a data quality score
associated with that, Nikki,
the agent on behalf of Nikki
might also put a constraint
saying, expose this data set
only if the data quality rule on a column
is greater than 95%.
I didn't show that in the agentic loop,
but that could be part of
your prompt template as well.
If you want data quality,
you can bake that into your agentic calls.
And data discoverability is
gonna be pretty important.
Your agents have to look
up your business catalog,
obtain potentially data products,
and then associate them
with the column metadata
in your technical catalog,
and retrieve the results.
Actually, I'm gonna talk
a little more detail
into how this trusted
identity propagation works.
Let's hold off for a second,
but you also have to
be, when Nikki logs in,
I simply said like, hey, by the way,
this agent is going to
actually take on that role.
How does that really happen?
I'll actually dig into
that towards the end.
Let's hold onto that.
And fine grained access control.
Users should only have
access to the dataset
that they need to look at.
We demonstrated this by
Athena rewriting the query
looking up Lake Formation.
And then the other piece is
performance is super important.
For example, if this report
takes forever to come back,
Nikki has to go get a coffee
or something like that.
Now maybe what we can do is actually use
a materialized view.
We've launched Glue Materialized
View last week, I think,
and then you can create,
Nikki can potentially create
a materialized view that says,
hey, create a materialized view for me
that only has records
from the state of Nevada.
So you don't have to actually,
Athena doesn't have to
actually scan all of that.
That should be baked in
in consumer priorities.
So far so good?
Okay, let's keep going.
Now, let's look at the
data producer experience.
Like what is the experience for Jane?
Jane, as I mentioned, is a data engineer.
In this example, Jane's task is gonna be
creating a data product,
and then Jane is going to
actually get this data set
from a telematics provider
and then host this in their environment.
Now, again, here, as Jane
starts talking to the agent,
the agent, first thing does
is inherits the user's role,
which is a data engineer.
Then this tool has all the
various tools required for,
like say MSK, MSK has a MCP server
and tools to provision a cluster
that's already exposed to this agent.
And then it simply says like, oh, okay,
I'm gonna create an MSK cluster,
and then creates the cluster,
and then actually fires up.
Then it realizes it needs
to also create a topic.
This is a placeholder for
all the streaming data
that's coming in.
Interestingly, the MCP
server there for MSK
does not have data plane access yet,
so it's gonna go through,
it's gonna realize,
hey, I don't see that tool there.
Maybe I should go through the front end
and actually create that.
So the agents are smart enough
to actually come up with code templates
that actually could go on with this,
with some prompts or
automatically realizing,
hey, I don't know how to
log on and create a topic.
And then that happens, and
then the thing unfolds.
The next step is it needs to provision
a kind of a Glue job,
since the template says
you want to use Spark, maybe
it uses Spark Streaming
to actually retrieve that data set.
And then actually the next thing it does
is it needs to create a table
where it needs to put that data set.
Remember the data quality
that we talked about?
This is the place
the producer has to
think about data quality.
Now, as part of doing that,
Jane also kind of writes,
data quality definition
language is something
that Amazon invented, and
we open source this as well.
A lot of our actually tools
automatically use this.
So what you can describe,
the data quality definition
language, what you want to do.
Like for example, if you
have GPS coordinates,
if you have speech, you can
simply say GPS coordinates
have to be within this range,
or speed has to be within this range.
All that is kind of baked in.
So as a part of creating this
table in the Glue catalog,
those quality rules can also be specified.
When you specify that, Glue
actually runs a batch job
and actually evaluate this rule,
and at the column level
says, here's the data quality
for your specific column, it's at 95%
or 90% based on how many
records are out of sync
with the rule specified there.
That's automatically built in.
It is Jane's responsibility
to go out and do that.
And then obviously the table gets created,
and that's the demo over.
In this case, Jane simply said like,
hey, don't create all this
stuff in my beta environment,
gimme the infrastructure as code.
I wanna validate this
code and then deploy this
using my classic CICD pipelines.
It's probably a good practice.
Don't have this running in
your production cluster.
Use a beta cluster if you want,
or at least create
infrastructure in the code
when you inspect this and
before you deploy this,
because otherwise you would
be affecting a running system.
And again, as the agentic loop spins,
it also realizes it needs to publish.
Jane is trying to publish a data,
this entire data set in
the business catalog.
It also publishes and enters
in the business catalog
for consumers to consume this.
And again, a data engineer has the ability
to publish to the business catalog.
That is the role that you already created.
And finally, it also associates,
it also says, let me actually
create Lake Formation
fine grained access control rules,
only these consumers can
access this data set,
that's actually baked in Lake Formation.
So all of this magic
happens behind the covers.
So this is a data producer experience
in the world of agents.
So let's look at the
priorities of the data producer
in the world of agents.
You know, we talked about
creating infrastructure,
the code, and verifying it.
The accuracy is still your job.
The agent is gonna come up with some code.
You want to ensure that
you have test scripts
and others to ensure that
this is actually doing
what you intend it to do.
That is the responsibility
of the producer.
And it's our responsibility,
it doesn't go away.
And data quality rules,
we saw how data quality definition rules
are associated with this data set.
That's a data producer's responsibility.
And also putting the
information a data catalog.
What does these columns mean?
What are the various bounds
and how should they be used?
All of that should be part
of your business catalog.
And then auditing.
Sometimes you figure out
why this happened, though.
So making sure that the audit is enabled,
so all of these accesses to Lake Formation
are already logged.
It can show up as a cloud trail.
That's a responsibility
of the data producer.
So far so good?
You know, I skipped one detail
as I was telling you, though.
I said, "By the way, the
agent inherits the role
of the user coming in."
Like, how does that really happen?
You only need a couple
of parameters, AWS IAM
as well as the OpenID Connect and OAuth2.
Rather than delving into
the details of this,
I'm gonna actually show you
how this really works under the covers.
Let's say you have a user,
the user first logs in
through their portal,
through the agent portal.
What happens at that point is,
the user gets authenticated
with the federated identity provider.
Now for Enterprise
Identity, it could be Okta.
Basically the user says,
hey, here's my user ID,
here's my login, here is your
MFA token that's in my device.
It plugs that in.
What that does is it sends out this thing
called a JWT token.
I didn't quite understand what this is.
I was trying to understand
what this is in detail.
Here's where, as data practitioners,
we have to understand the primitives
of what these things mean.
The easiest way to imagine
this is your license,
driver's license.
We're talking about insurance,
easy to use driver's license.
In your driver's license,
you have your name,
you have your picture,
you have your signature,
and the age details, et cetera.
That's your ID.
And you give that ID to
someone else they know,
they look at this thing and
they look at your picture
and says, yeah, I think that's the person.
And it also has this entitlements.
Which is what class of car,
I live in the state of Washington,
default is a driver C class license.
It doesn't say that,
but that's the default.
And it also has a restriction
for me called restriction B,
which means, in the US it
means I have to wear glasses
or contact lenses to drive my car.
That's the entitlements.
So what the JWT token
is, it's the access token
and the permission token.
So that's what this thing is like.
You send the token to the agent,
that token has to be passed along.
There are a couple of use cases here.
One, where the identity
provider doesn't change
in your organization.
That is Nikki's use case.
Nikki runs a query
and then that gets passed
onto the tool, et cetera.
At each stage it checks
with the identity provider
if need be, and then passes
faithfully the token along,
the identity token and the
access token along to the APIs.
And beyond the APIs, it's the same path.
Those credentials may be exchanged
with their temporary AWS credentials.
You know, single sign on, and
then it talks to the database,
or it could be using a user ID, password,
and then you get the details
from your secure store.
Then there's another path sometimes.
Remember, in the case of Jane,
Jane is actually getting a data set
from a telematics provider.
The telematics provider might use
a different identity provider.
In that case, what happens is that,
you need to exchange your credentials.
Like you're showing your driver's license,
and if you're gonna go to another country,
they don't take US driver's license.
You gotta go to AAA and say,
"Can you gimme an international
driver's license?"
What they take is they look at your ID
and then actually they
give you new credentials.
They print this paper and say,
"This is your international
driver's license."
Then if you go to another
country, you show them,
and they let you rent the car.
That's really what happens.
The Bedrock identity allows
you to actually do that
on your behalf.
It's like accessing a
token winding machine.
It takes that and gives you other tokens
that you can use in your other systems.
So that thing is what happens,
as you can just see here.
Then you send those tokens
faithfully to your tools,
and then that gets
propagated to the API call
that you're making,
and at that point those
credentials could get transformed
into IAM credentials that can be used
to access your data store.
Or in this case whatever
credentials that's required
to access this third party telematics,
telematics use case.
So, this thing is super important.
As data practitioners
and AI practitioners,
we really have to delve into,
how do we tell our agent
to act on our behalf,
and it's super important,
otherwise it can go do kind
of unpredictable things.
Now putting it all together.
This is the final set of slides.
Are you ready?
Five minutes, all right?
This is the most exciting part for me.
So I'm gonna try to put all this
in a single reference architecture
that you can probably take a look at.
Here we go, let's go.
This is external user.
This is Terry coming in
and asking a question.
I wanna buy car insurance.
So you're building an agentic app.
Maybe you're using Strands,
maybe you're using LangChain,
maybe you're using other frameworks.
Now, we think that
Amazon Bedrock Agent Code
is the best place to run this,
because it gives you a runtime,
which is pretty secure, containerized.
So that's just owned by that execution.
Tim talked about memory,
short term memory and long term memory,
those constructs are there.
We talked about the Gateway.
Like if you have APIs, you
can quickly expose them
as tools by using Gateway.
We talked about identity,
this thing where you show your ID to AAA
and get that other ID, all of that magic
can be actually simplified
by your AgentCore identity.
That's why we feel this is,
I haven't discussed a
few other things there,
AgentCore is the best place to run this.
Now, this doesn't have to be
for your external customers.
All your internal teams are
going to, as we move forward,
are gonna have agents that
they potentially build,
or this may be like IDs,
like KIRO or other IDs,
agent IDs that you can prompt
and use that for internal
deployments as well,
as long as you can hook
up all your tools to this.
This is the way this looks.
Remember Amazon Bedrock LLMs,
Amazon Bedrock has a choice of LLM,
all the way from Nova, to Anthropic, to,
every year we add a few more LLMs,
because you can use the right LLM
for your reasoning tasks.
So we give you a choice of LLMs.
And then remember Bedrock knowledge bases.
You can basically, Bedrock
can actually take your string
and then actually look up, on your behalf,
the knowledge base and retrieve
other pieces of information.
Like we have a host of functionality there
in terms of Postgres, if
you have a Postgres engine,
if you're doing a SQL, if
you're familiar with that,
if you wanna use the engine,
you can use the Vector
capability in Postgres,
through PG Vector.
OpenSearch is fantastic
to combine vector searches
along with the classic searches.
So we have a host of tools there.
If you're doing Graph
Rag, you can use Neptune
as your vector store,
where you can do both the graph reversals
as well as vector searches together.
We also have S3 vectors that we added.
Milan yesterday talked about that.
And then you can use that,
and then you can also
expose them as MCP tools.
Like we talked about this
API where you give the string
and it it fetches a related
piece of information.
If you have an MCP server,
you can build an MCP
for this server for that and
expose that as a tool as well.
Now this is sort of the front end.
Now Tim talked about
packaging this as APIs.
Remember the special purpose
path that Tim talked about?
You creating canned queries or APIs?
Now, those things, if you
expose them as MCP tools,
both your customer facing
agents and your internal agents
can actually talk to
those backend engines.
Now we have a lot of capability,
starting from Aurora, to
DynamoDB, to ElastiCache,
to Redshift, Athena, and
the list keeps on growing.
Based on what tool you want,
what engine runs it the
best, you can expose your API
or general purpose query via this tool.
Now what happens to your backend?
There we go.
That's the data processing engine.
This is where Jane goes and
provisions a Kafka topic
and then actually runs a Glue job.
That whole thing can be
orchestrated by tools.
With that, this is the picture
I've been very intensely drawing.
Hopefully this makes sense.
So this is, I feel like
a reference architecture,
at least for me, until I keep changing it,
we'll keep on tweaking this.
Any feedback on this is welcome.
On the left side is the agent.
On the right side is the data.
The MCP is this big USB, USB-C thing
that connects the data and AI together,
and this is how the magic happens, folks.
And with that, I wanna leave
you with a call for action.
To me, I think the special purpose paths
are something that you have to build.
I would start building data APIs.
As Tim pointed out, these
are very easy to build.
It gives you a secure path,
but you can also build data products
and give you a general purpose path.
That's a little more risky.
So you can use both,
but I would urge you to build APIs,
expose them as MCP tools
via the MCP protocol.
As we talked about data governance,
end-to-end security are the top priority.
You should be thinking about them day one,
not after the fact when your
agent vents out the data
that it should not vent out.
And finally, we are working very hard
to simplify this experience for you
so you can focus on your business
and leave the other muck to us.
So with that, I wanna end the session.
Thank you very much.
I hope this was meaningful.
Your feedback is very welcome.
(audience applauds)